there are soap operas in the NBA and
then there is what's going on in
Minnesota if you know me if you're
around me you know my heart you know how
I go about what I go about the Minnesota
Timberwolves who right now are the team
dealing with the most drama entering the
season because Jimmy Butler wants out
Jimmy Butler returns to practice for the
Minnesota Timberwolves and then inserts
himself where was the starters against
the third stringers and he inserts
himself into the lineup with the third
stringers and beat the brakes off them
kids he were loud emotional targeting
coach Tom Thibodeau teammates like
karl-anthony towns
Andrew Wiggins you told Jim Scott lately
you effing need me all my emotions came
out I can't control that when I'm out
there competing was out brutally honest
yes I think the destin'd everybody's so
scared to be honest when we hear that
he's not love with some of his teammates
guys don't work hard enough Jamie tell
us why you want Noah to know to go
through something like this man he's the
trait this thing will implode and I
don't think it
you still are betrayed
maybe Butler asked for a trade during a
meeting with team president but that
does not mean the Timberwolves have to
grant his request karl-anthony towns
straining under this distraction I
thought Jimmy Hamilton situation poorly
I think he really tried this Timothy
Wiggins in town he's really had a
negative effect I don't know
tomorrow so I can't tell you Jimmy's
going to be a guy who's going to come
out you direct all the time that's who
he is
you definitely have made the wrong
giving up in the vein marking it done
done and then for 58 to 60 games you get
Butler and now you got to make another
move they need to act on it because
that's the one thing that unequivocally
derails a season I think this is a very
good trade for the victors Jimmy
Butler's predicament has gotten a
significantly different for emotional
last 48 hours metalphoto they had to do
something I'm very excited I think you
can be really really good I can be
difficult at times but I swear is this
from the right place right now teams
like Milwaukee teams like Toronto have
went ahead of Philadelphia this boy is
where he's Philadelphia right back into
that race we work so hard and I study my
game and everybody else's your franchise
player you got
before Jenny Butler came in just a
defensive minded guy
others but the image I'm just gonna work
keep working and work some more now
every night we will have those all-star
MVP type legs where both ends of the
floor and now you able to get but we'd
like to show tonight
have a new opportunity to do that here
Kennywood adhere it
second
but once these guys get it once they
come together this is a very tough
ballclub I like to help his chances I'm
passionate about I love the game and I
love doing you know how good of a team
you are
we're supposed to perform so that I'm
going out there and joining tonight was
an awesome example of when he's good he
is that good for this team we are
starting to see good signs I'm sorry
I'll go about it the wrong way I really
do apologize stop me if you've heard
this before Jimmy Butler not happy when
you're 25 and 14 you're playing as well
as they're playing it's unusual to have
that level of this content
[Music]
this is Jimmy's third stop he's had
problems whether it be with young
players coaches other star players at
every single stop he's probably told
Brett when he came over look I run hot
this is how I work I'm really
competitive I'm gonna burst out once in
a while Kevin Love was not happy with
his role he didn't challenge to Lou
he eventually figured out how to play
with LeBron James because he was not the
best player on that team I don't know
Jimmy Butler has gotten that memo that
indeed if it is the best player on that
team the conflict ain't always bad now
if I can get him focused on the game
plan it's all I'm asking you do your job
you don't have to hang out with him but
when we out on the floor all I'm asking
and demanding is to do your job in
between those lines everything is purely
whatever it's bothering about step one
for therefore I don't think about
anything I just want to move it so
whatever I'm out there it's all about
one
that's the reason why everybody plays
this game is to win a championship
great customer titles are
since it plays a year great
that trophy canary knowing that
at point in time you're the best team
you couldn't mess with anybody on the
team because somebody else was always
gonna be there in your face we got to
figure out first of all having a score
enough points against Toronto stifling
defense yeah
how bad you play the point in a game is
to win
well why heavy low for him took over the
basketball game they did a nice job to
Ronald's just grind in this map where
Islanders the best defender congruent I
just feel like he's gonna deal with
Galaga
all mine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not going would hopefully I'll
get a marriage contract anywhere I
choose to go if it gets out that
Philadelphia does not offer him max it
will be a very bad sign giving up what
they gave up if they don't resign Butler
man are they gonna be in serious trouble
Jimmy Butler doesn't really sign back
where does Philadelphia go from there if
you're the Lakers you go out the Jimmy
Butler is he gonna get in line with
LeBron James